aquí está la reacción general para la
apertura de anillo de epoxy 2 cuando
todo está catalizado por ácido si
empiezo primero mirando a mi epoxi do de
la izquierda puedo clasificar este
carbono y puedo ver que este carbono
está unido a otros 2 carbonos por lo que
este carbono sera
según diario
o puedo pensar en un hidrógeno
reemplazando el grupo r y entonces sería
un carbono primario
podría ser tanto primario como
secundario si veo al carbono en el lado
derecho este carbono de aquí está unido
a otros 3 carbonos por lo que este
carbono a la derecha sería
diario
así que si hago reaccionar este epoxy
dow con un núcleo filo débil
hn representa mi núcleo filo
de bits
y lago una reacción catalizada por ácido
puedo ver el producto aquí a la derecha
el núcleo filo se ha sumado al carbono
más sustituido así que aquí puedo ver mi
núcleo fino lo agrego a mi carbono
terciario aquí en la derecha esto es la
región química un ataque núcleo físico
del carbono más sustituido y puedo ver
cuando el anillo se abre el grupo h va a
ser anti al núcleo filo observemos una
reacción y podemos ir a través del
mecanismo entero para esta apertura de
anillo
si empiezo con bióxido continuaré y lo
haré
de este modo tendré mi epoxy do viniendo
hacia mí
y luego en este carbono de arriba
un grupo
metilo alejándose de m
aquí está mi grupo metilo voy a hacer
reaccionar
este epoxi do con etanol así que
continuaré y pondré al etanol aquí
el etanol será mi núcleo filo débil y
esta catalizada por ácido así que me
aseguraré de eso poniendo mis protones
aquí de esta manera
continuamos y dibujemos el óxido para
que podamos verlo un poco mejor vamos a
estar viendo desde arriba nuestro epoxi
do de esta manera por lo tanto el
oxígeno va a estar arriba relativo al
plano del anillo un par libre de
electrones en el oxígeno así y luego en
este carbono va a haber un grupo metilo
yendo hacia abajo
el primer paso del mecanismo es una
reacción ácido base
esta es una reacción catalizada por
ácido por lo que hay
h más
protones flotando alrededor
un par de electrones libres en el
oxígeno van a tomar a ese protón voy a
protón army óxido cuando dibujo el
producto de esa reacción ácido base
y ahora tengo en mi oxígeno aún tengo un
par de electrones libres el otro par
libre formó un enlace con ese protón por
lo que ahora es un epoxi do protón a do
lo que le da al oxígeno una carga formal
de más 1
aún necesito tener mi grupo metilo abajo
del anillo de esta manera
y ahora cuando pienso en el siguiente
paso necesito pensar en la clasificación
de los átomos de carbono
si miro este carbono de arriba puedo ver
que está unido a otros 3 carbonos por lo
que este es mi carbono terciario el de
aquí abajo es solo secundario y sé que
el núcleo filo va a atacar al carbono
más sustituido el cual será este de aquí
abajo justo así por lo que este es el
carbono que será atacado
si pienso en ese oxígeno estando cargado
positivamente al oxígeno no le gusta
estar cargado positivamente el oxígeno
es muy electro negativo así que hará
todo lo que pueda para jalar algunos de
estos electrones el enlace entre ese
carbono y el oxígeno un poco más cerca
al oxígeno de ahí así que disminuir un
poco de densidad electrónica de este
carbono por lo que este carbono va a
terminar teniendo una carga parcial
positiva así
y si pienso en qué tipo de carbón será
tiene un poco de carácter parcial de
carbó catión y puedo pensar en el hecho
de que ese carbono está unido a esos
otros tres carbonos es un poco más
sencillo verlo aquí hay 12
carbonos más y en vídeos anteriores
hemos visto que los carbó cationes
terciarios son los más estables mucho
más estables que los carbó cationes
secundarios
y si tengo un núcleo filo débil atacando
este atacara el carbono más sustituido
por lo que va a atacar el que sería el
carb ocasión más estable así que otra
vez tenemos más de un carácter parcial
de carbó catión aquí pero cuando el
núcleo filo débil se presenta ese par
libre de electrones va a atacar este
carbono de aquí y eso va a mandar estos
electrones de aquí los de magenta al
oxígeno así que continuemos y dibujemos
los resultados del ataque el núcleo
físico
tengo mi anillo justo aquí y he abierto
mi epoxi 2 por lo que ahora este oxígeno
va a pasarse a la izquierda aquí y está
unido a un hidrógeno tenía un par de
electrones libres y acaba de tomar un
par más de electrones libres los que
estaban en magenta y en el transcurso
del ataque el núcleo físico
el grupo metilo que está abajo relativo
al anillo es empujado hacia arriba por
lo que el grupo metilo va a terminar
arriba relativo al anillo y tengo un par
de electrones libres de la molécula de
etanol que están unidos ahora a este
carbono
puedo continuar y mostrar esos
electrones y hay un oxígeno un hidrógeno
y luego dos carbonos y luego hay aún un
par de electrones libres en el oxígeno
lo que le da a ese oxígeno una carga
formal de más 1 así que continuemos y
remarquemos esos electrones muy rápido
veamos los haré rojos aquí estos
electrones de aquí esos son los que
atacan el carbono y esos son los que
formaron estos enlaces covalentes de
esta manera casi terminamos el último
paso será una reacción ácido base para
deshacernos de esa carga formal de +1 en
el oxígeno por lo que necesitamos otra
molécula de etanol esta va a actuar como
una base
así que continuaré dibujando otra
molécula de etanol
y tiene paredes libres de electrones en
ella
uno de esos pares libres de electrones
va a tomar
protón que manda a estos dos electrones
a este oxígeno y vamos a terminar con
nuestros productos
continuemos y dibujemos el producto
justo aquí y como siempre vamos a estar
viendo a nuestra molécula desde arriba y
entonces vamos a mirar hacia abajo desde
aquí
y dibujaremos lo que vemos así que
tendremos nuestro anillo así
y en el carbono de arriba que sería este
puedo ver que hay un grupo metilo
saliendo hacia mí por lo que continuaré
poniendo mi grupo metilo saliendo hacia
mí así y luego alejándose de mí voy a
tener mi oxígeno por supuesto estoy
hablando de este oxígeno de aquí abajo
y puedo continuar dibujando ese oxígeno
alejándose de mí y unido a ese oxígeno
por supuesto estarían 2 carbonos puedo
continuar haciendo eso y cuando veo ese
carbono a la izquierda ahí y ahora estoy
hablando de este carbono puedo ver que
hay un grupo o h saliendo hacia mí en el
espacio pondré ese grupo o h saliendo
hacia mí en el espacio justo ahí y eso
será nuestro producto una vez más pondré
mis dos pares libres de electrones en el
oxígeno porque mostré a ese protón
siendo removido en el último paso del
mecanismo ahí
ahora veamos la estéreo química
empecemos primero con este carbono de
arriba así que vuelvo a mis reactivos y
veo este carbono de arriba y pienso en
el hecho de que tengo una cuña hacia un
oxígeno por lo que el oxígeno está
saliendo hacia mí y el carbono está
alejándose de mí en el espacio cuando
veo a mis productos este sería el
carbono que corresponde a ese carbono es
el opuesto ahora tengo un carbono
saliendo hacia mí en el espacio y un
oxígeno alejándose de mí
eso es inversión de configuración por lo
que en el carbono de arriba en este
carbono de aquí voy a obtener la
inversión
con
nación
así que está involucrada un poco de
estéreo química y cuando veo al otro
carbono cuando veo a este carbono de
aquí puedo ver que hay un oxígeno
saliendo hacia mí en el espacio y cuando
veo a ese carbono de mis productos veo
que aún hay un oxígeno saliendo hacia mí
en el espacio por lo que es la misma
configuración absoluta en este carbono
solo vemos inversión de configuración en
el carbono que está experimentando el
ataque el núcleo físico que es el
carbono más sustituido